I've been sounding the alarm now for
more than a year that YouTube is
becoming corporate media that channels
like the david pakman show and others
are starting to be strangled and i even
identified the specific metrics that
confirmed this and now YouTube is not
not only admitting it they are bragging
about it like it's a really good thing
and I'm going to talk about that so
let's reset the David Pakman show
depends on YouTube recommending our
videos to viewers okay we have a nice
YouTube channel nearly 800,000
subscribers thanks to you but
historically the way that our channel
has grown is that somebody will watch a
CNN video or they'll watch another
independent video they much what might
watch Sam cedar for example and then
some of those people would get the idea
of watching a david pakman show video
after that by the recommendations that
show up on the side or below that
YouTube suggests and then some people
would click on to the david pakman show
video and then some portion of those
would say I like this I'm going to hit
subscribe now we've got a new subscriber
now historically anywhere from 50 to 70%
of our monthly viewers are not from our
existing subscriber base so we really
depend on YouTube doing that so what
happened well what you have to
understand is that when you were dealing
with a corporation that is doing stuff
and it knows that a lot of people will
be furious about the things that they
are doing they don't just tell you what
they're doing they use sort of like
coded corporate English I would call it
if someone was speaking Spanish and you
spoke English you'd need a translator to
go from Spanish to English in the same
way if you are listening to corporate
coded English and you just want to
understand like normal person English
it needs a translation so late last year
in 2018 YouTube said we will start
prioritizing authoritative sources
oh that sounds kind of reasonable right
they say yeah we're gonna prioritize
authoritative sources so that we're not
promoting hate speech or content that
violates terms and conditions what they
mean by authoritative is corporate media
/ independent
like the David Pakman show and we got
crushed we actually saw the views that
were coming from YouTube's
recommendations algorithm drop from
roughly four million views per month to
somewhere between one and one and a half
million views per month for a channel
like ours to instantly lose two and a
half million views per month it's a lot
of money it's a lot of money so I've
been quiet about this for months we've
been grinding it out doing our videos
doing our show because I can't do a damn
thing about it
I told you some months ago that I don't
want to annoy the audience with this
stuff because every time I do a story
about this I know I'm spending some of
my political capital with my audience
because there are people who get annoyed
by these stories and some of you
evaporate every time I talk about this
but it's getting worse and YouTube is
now confirming that they are doing this
and the effect is brutal
so again we have to interpret corporate
speak now the terms we have to interpret
are borderline content and what it means
that YouTube claims that they are
succeeding that their policy is working
to stifle borderline content because
when they talk about borderline content
it's not just white nationalist stuff
it's not just hate speech it's all the
independent news content like our
channel that gets wrapped up with the
hate content and not recommended and it
crushes us crushes us when YouTube now
says that this is working what they mean
is the algorithm changes they've made
are correctly recommending corporate
content over hours and it's a disaster
Nathan recently sent me a screenshot of
how bad it is Nathan said he'll add a
ton of our videos to his watch later
queue on YouTube but then when those
finish up the queue will start
automatically getting filled up with
corporate media content in this case
it's showing Nathan videos from Seth
Meyers late night show
often it's CNN Fox News MSNBC content
from other you know hundred million
dollar budget shows like John Oliver's
so I know that this is a pain when I
talk about this I'm making a concerted
effort to talk about this much less but
now that we're getting ready to end the
year I did
want to tell you what is going on
because I know many of you are watching
the algorithm and you write to me and
you say David I'm just watching your
stuff liking your stuff and yet YouTube
keeps recommending CNN this is a feature
not a bug as far as YouTube is concerned
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki is admitting
it YouTube made 30 changes since January
of this year I'm not aware of any that
helped us
although YouTube of course won't tell us
what they changed one of the issues is
what is considered brand safety for
running ads I have recently been told
that anything that mentions abortion is
not brand safe if you are an independent
channel like us takes the issue off the
table if you want to be able to monetize
your content I won't even mention the
other things that are total no-goes
because I don't want to get this video
demonetized merely by mentioning those
things but there are a lot more no-go
topics if you want to run ads another
issue constant bogus copyright claims
you know if you paid attention a few
weeks ago to our impeachment streams we
ran the House of Representatives feed
during impeachment streams CNN was
claiming our videos for copyright
violation NBC The Associated Press
fraudulent claims that crush us I'm
asking YouTube how can I fight these in
mass because appealing each one
individually is is nuts
they're filing them endlessly no answer
from YouTube so please consider pushing
back against this by supporting shows
you like directly I'm saying support us
sure or other show whatever show you
think is valuable we have made really
big progress this year we've actually
added more members in 2019 than in any
other year and this is insulating us
partially from what YouTube is doing but
it's gonna ramp up in 2020 with so much
more corporate media content about the
election we are going to get crowded out
by the algorithm so consider getting a
very cheap membership at join pakman.com
our year-end coupon code is last 2019
this is 66% off okay 66% off with the
coupon code last 2019 it's very cheap
and
humbly asking for your support also
consider throwing us a dollar or two on
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show all of this stuff helps give
to us give to shows you value just
understand the stakes here and the
importance of your support given what is
going on with YouTube one of our
sponsors is privacy comm they're giving
you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy comm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance
I love using free trials because I know
I won't be charged when the trial is
over if I use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan that gives you one
percent cashback and lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a twenty five
dollar a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at
IVA si.com / Pakman